stargate is going to be returning to our
screens but what is it going to look
like and what are the risks of the new
series
we want stargate not star trek right
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so i've been talking a lot in past
videos about the return of stargate and
how excited i am about getting this tv
show back on our screens
but the more i learn about the two pilot
scripts that are currently being
developed and plans by amazon and mgm to
create this stargate franchise once
again to return the sleeping giant of
sci-fi to our screens
the more concerned i get
so let's just start off with brad wright
a lot of people say we want brad right
back involved in this or god oh i'm not
watching it that's it don't i'm not
having it
i i'm not really that bothered about
brad wright coming back or not i just
want the show to be run right to be
honest if the show comes back and it's
brilliant i don't really care who
produces it who writes it who directs it
or whatever
i just want a good show
and to be honest i'm not the biggest fan
of sgu even though sg-1 and stargate
atlantis were two of my favorite tv
shows probably ever
stargate universe just wasn't
i thought it was kind of boring if i'm
100 honest um even though i thought
stargate universe was absolutely
beautifully made i just basically
thought it was dull and obviously brad
wright was massively involved in that so
i can't really argue that everything he
touches is gold
so therefore i'm not 100 certain i
actually want him back involved i do
wonder if new blood might be a good idea
saying that if brad wright comes back
and knocks out the park i don't really
care either and i will
swallow my words and apologize to him
personally on twitter but whoever
actually runs the show there are going
to be some risks here because
stargate does have a bit of an identity
when they bring stargate back from me
they do need to bring back some of the
humor that they lost in sgu they do we
need to bring back that tone that sg-1
and sga had that sgu lacked
in that i mean the kind of the tone the
sort of cheeky sense of humor that went
with it but also sort of like there's
always grounded in an element of realism
that's the main risk i have with this
new stargate series coming along and why
i say i want stargate not star trek
the problem is
during stargate sg1 we went from
basically having no alien technology to
having the mbc 304s at the end the
deadlifts etc according to stargate
cannon in 2000 we developed the f301 a
hybrid of gold crashed technology and
you know reversed engineer technology
two years after that we had the f302 a
completely reversed engineered or
human-built fighter interceptor a year
after that in 2003 the prometheus was
launched the bc303 and it was only two
years after that that the daedalus was
launched the first bc 304 now these
battle cruisers and fighters were
generally armed with sort of
conventional weapon systems for us they
had railguns which is actually a
technology we have now and so it's not
that beyond our you know
current capabilities technologically but
we had missiles the main reason why the
f302s are so effective against death
gliders is because of our missiles and
they had greater range and we could hit
the death glider much further out the
prometheus and the deadliest main
ornament were basically vertically
launched missile systems and railguns
now they did have the quadri-enriched
nuclear weapons which were pretty
powerful but still we were talking about
basically taking missiles to a directed
energy weapon fight but within 10 years
don't forget from the start of su-1 to
the end of sg-1 we've gone from
basically nothing to having the bc
is powered by
asgard shields
asgard weapon systems and asgard engines
we actually had the asgard new directed
energy weapon that they developed for
the aura this was their most powerful
weapon they'd ever developed and we were
mounting them on the bc304s
all of a sudden the terry had one of the
most powerful fleets anywhere
the asgard were gone
but their weapons that they'd been
developing for tens of thousands of
years lived on aboard our ships
our shields were better than anyone
else's our weapons were better than
anyone else's now that was a massive
leap in technology and obviously then
the asgard left us with their data core
an arc of all of their accumulated
knowledge
we've then had another 10 15 nearly 20
years to work on that technology and to
learn as much as we can from the asgards
surely by now we'll have launched the
bc305s or even
bc306s we're going to develop a far more
advanced starship
we're going to potentially be now using
directed energy weapon sidearms
rifles
what other technology will we have
acquired and become normal it does look
like that from what we know of brad
wright's pilot and from what we've seen
of this mysterious second pilot please
go back and check previous videos
that the stargate is now no longer a
secret it is out there for the world to
know
then the opening sequence of the new
stargate pilot is the stargate sat in
the middle of a very large open glass
and steel structure that looks almost
like an airport so if the secrets out
and the technological advancements have
now become too big to hide what does
that mean for the show
are we going to get star trek style
sci-fi instead of what we know as star
stargate
is this going to be a lot of starships
flying around
are we going to have like phases are we
going to have other aliens running
around that are part of some sort of new
empire that we're the humanity is now
forging sg-1 was always the plucky
underdog fighting against incredible
odds
even when we battled the alright that
was the same thing even though we were
far more technologically advanced we
were still fighting an enemy that we had
we could barely even fathom never mind
actually stand up and fight against but
they did they fought and fought and
eventually won
now the technology is so far advanced
where is that enemy
for example the lucian alliance they're
not really going to be a threat even
though they have very large numbers of
attacks and other gold technology that
they acquired as the gold collapsed
our ships will kick their ass
it wouldn't really matter how many
attacks they had
if we've got this asgard technology the
asgard had far fewer numbers in the gold
world for thousands of years but they
kept the gold at bay basically because
the gold shields could not cope with
their weapon systems
and the weapon systems we have are
better than those so the lucian alliance
even though they have far greater
numbers and will have far greater
influence in the galaxy than us
would not be able to go toe to toe with
any of our ships
they could have three or four attacks
one of our ships would turn up and just
put holes through all of them
and that for me is the biggest risk for
this new stargate series
we've acquired too much technology we've
become too advanced we're no longer the
plucky underdog
we're king of the hill
so where is the threat gonna come from
now i've already told you that it looks
like the anunnaki or at very least a
species that is kind of based on this
ancient aliens idea of this first gods
this giant seas anunnaki is going to be
the inspiration for the villain for the
new series and i wonder whether they
might be a partly ascended or maybe an
actually fully ascended but a returning
species so that we're going to be
actually taking on this ascended enemy
very much like we did against the ori
but obviously we didn't really go
toe-to-toe with the ori as much as their
armies
in this case we might actually be going
toe-to-toe with the actual ancient
species now that would be a significant
threat and the technology we have really
wouldn't matter at that point so we
would be back to being the plucky
underdog i suppose
please get into the comments and tell me
what do you think is stargate at risk of
becoming the next star trek is it going
to be too advanced is it going to be
nothing like sg1 sga sgu is it going to
be completely different and therefore
not really stargate anymore and if you
want to become a fully fledged
sidetracker you can join the channel and
support us hit the join button and
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification hit all the thumbs up not
the thumbs down that helps nobody um and
um
really you know share the video wherever
the hell you like thanks for watching
and as always guys please stay safe i'll
see you next time
[Music]